[Music]
you've been very vocal in saying that
you think chris harrison needs to do the
work
do you think he should come back at all
that's a decision that he has to make
you know with the
the franchise um for me i'm just focused
on my season and trying to find love
let the journey begin i was just very
blessed to have tasha and caitlyn kind
of help me through that journey
and it's something that i will forever
be thankful for
former bachelorettes tasha and caitlin
have stepped in as co-hosts for chris
this season
they bring plenty of girl power to
season 17 of the bachelorette which
premieres tonight
on abc oh
that's just the beginning
how sexy does it get i mean i have sex
in the fantasy suites
so you heard it here first but this
season is in all fantasy hookups katie
told me
during the pop-up picnic event over the
weekend there's also drama
and tears a bomb was dropped on me about
multiple people still here for the wrong
reason
we see you saying do i continue or do i
get like basically get the heck out of
here
yeah i'm done someone booked my flight
home
i'll just say you know this journey's
not easy and if it wasn't for tasha and
caitlyn and some other people that you
guys will find out about
i don't know that i could have done it
okay let me see that left hand
i'm looking for a tan line
are you engaged i mean i'm engaged to
myself that's what i've been saying for
now
you can tell me if you're in love i mean
i will say this
i fall in love more than once